these steers are unregistered and
illegal they have no legitimate markings
some have yellow tags indicating only
that they've been sold
they're from the amazon rainforest from
farms that have no legitimacy the land
has been stolen
but these cattle will eventually enter
the world's food supply chain re-badged
as legal
it's a conspiracy worth millions
beef washing with the amazon at its
heart the vital link between climate
change and cattle is simple
eighty percent of the forest being cut
down here is carried out by ranchers
the amazon is being destroyed so that
you can eat beef
this is what it looks like when the
farmers move in
the trees simply disappear
never to return
this is para state in the amazon and it
looks like this everywhere you go
brazil is the world's number one
exporter of beef much of it at the
expense of the forest that keeps the
planet breathing
a recent audit of the world's biggest
meat packing company found it had bought
over 300 000 cows from paris state that
had irregularities basically beef washed
into the regular market from rainforest
farms
the animals are transported hundreds of
miles by truck you see them everywhere
you go there are 210 steer in these two
lorries
they've been traveling for seven days
with no food or water
they've been parked here for hours
the metal of the truck is so hot you
can't touch it
farmers tell us that the steers can lose
up to 35 kilograms each just from the
travel
this unregulated and illegal business is
rarely seen
sky news given unparalleled access into
this murky world of beef production by
unrepentant farmers who believe it is
their right
to produce
[Music]
a
exhausted from days in a truck for a few
hours these steers arrested before the
next part of their journey a river
transporter barge on a tributary of the
amazon
they're driven towards the metal loading
ramp of the barge
[Applause]
slipping and sliding and tramping on
each other
with no regulation no controls and
certainly no vets their well-being
appears to be utterly ignorant
one of the steers doesn't make it up the
ramp and gets stuck
so began over an hour of brutal efforts
to get him to move
the ranchers start by kicking him in his
face
trying to rile him to stand
clearly in terrible distress the men
then force his head underwater
i hope the steer fearing he is drowning
will be spurred on
the animal must be terrified he
struggles forward and collapses
legs splayed apart
he's badly injured now and he still
isn't on board
anyone who's seen animals being treated
particularly when they're being taken
away to slaughter know that it's pretty
gruesome but this is very nasty
incidents in that animal is absolutely
exhausted the point is it's all part of
unregulated trade
nobody knows where that beef is going to
end up it could be in britain it could
be in europe it could be in argentina it
could be in brazil and that's the real
issue here nobody's across what's
happening and of course
the treatment any of the sort of usual
strictures don't really exist
and finally they resort to a block and
tackle
ropes are tied around the horns
and he is slowly hauled into the barge
this beef will eventually be certified
and exported
and none of us will ever know it came
from the rainforest
produced to satisfy demand
stuart ramsey sky news in the amazon
you